this genuinely feels like it might be
like
one of the most hyped
uh movie trailers of all time
we love a multiverse it's just
the possibilities you know they're fun
in the comics
they were awesome and into the spider
verse which is
probably one of the best movies ever
made like unironically i don't think
that this trailer which by the way what
we're watching here is spider-man no way
home official trailer
um i don't feel like they're gonna give
me like all of the multiverse stuff that
i'm hoping for like i want to see all of
our spider-man's come back that's what i
want
seems unlikely but the idea is so
exciting um
that i know a lot of people have been
very excited to see this trailer i
believe that they had like an in-person
viewing
for it which i if that's a thing i had
no idea
and um this video already has three
million views and it only dropped like a
number of hours ago so
let's
do it
what do you got for us
[Music]
that is it
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spider-man
exposition there it's all right we
started getting some visitors
[Applause]
i got chills every
universe
hello peter ah
so cool obviously we knew about him
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please very nice very nice
[Music]
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean they
all die fighting spiderman
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
i do think that's pretty ooh
look there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our universe
[Music]
you're not gonna take this away from me
i'll get to it
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
ah
she falls again
[Applause]
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop him
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november oh
that's interesting
back to exclusively in movie theaters i
feel like i i'll i'll go see it and see
it in cinemas um
okay so this trailer is very cool we
didn't get all the other actor cameos
that i necessarily expected but they're
probably more exciting
to wait for them um
lots of things that i found to be
interesting but i'm gonna say
this right here
obviously
that really does just look like cg when
we pause on it that's not zendaya um
obviously an iconic moment that was not
invented by andrew garfield however
given the setting
i wonder if we could see a universe
where one of the other
alternate dimension spideys comes in and
saves her that
this is always foretold
as she falls that's what happens um but
maybe
in this instance she doesn't and then
because because this version of peta
cannot save this version of mj that
can't happen
maybe a different
peter
will come through the multiverse and
save her from the bottom or jump through
or something that that would be
very neat man this is exciting a lot a
lot of good shots that's even that i
think we saw that before but that's
gorgeous
yeah this is super exciting and it's
also the um
the city melting shot got me because
that's so
much like into the spider verse which
might be like the toughest thing that
this movie has to deal with for me
personally
is that i genuinely think into the
spider-verse
is the best marble movie it's like it's
so so so good even though it's a sony
movie it's not actually a marvel marvel
movie um
that's just so [ __ ] fantastic that
like
that's what this is competing with i'm
sure when i see it i'll be able to
separate it obviously the mcu was like
built up to this point for so long and
spider-man movies are always just so
easy to get behind peter is
intentionally very very relatable and i
feel like you know of of even the worst
spider-man movies i feel like i always
feel that way i always care about peter
parker
um
that that's always going to be there so
maybe maybe i won't even remember and
like i said they built up the the tom
holland spider-man for so long i feel
like we know him so well we've watched
this dude age that's especially why like
this first shot
what was it i don't remember it was like
the one right here that oh
damn dude
that
weighs heavy on you that is rough
um
this is really exciting i appreciate
that the trailer didn't give me too much
and didn't give too much away it just
got me a little bit more hyped for
something i was already excited to see
um let's oh dislikes are gone it's my
first time noticing that
uh let's see
what the internet has to say
they all die fighting spider-man except
for lizard and salmon who are just there
to make friends
toby makes cameos pizza little riga
that's exactly what i thought
if andrew garfield spider-man
is inside the suit when saving mj oh
well i guess we interpreted that
differently my guess was that it's still
it's still tom holland that we're seeing
in that shot but that andrew garfield
shows up
um but again it's not necessary because
it's like it's just so
canon wait you said who saved her who
said he saved it oh right right right
right yeah i mean she could just
actually die it that is a thing that
happens to spider-man yeah that that is
a thing i'm not sure how to make i agree
elektra does look very good very good
it is the toughest thing that the mcu
has to deal with this is this stuff is
said this the shalin kawali said the
avengers straight chillin while the
apocalypse is literally happening they
are technically gone yes
the eternals
uh
such a such a problem with with any of
the big comic book arcs is like why
isn't anybody helping batman where is
superman he can get here in a second
it's like it's so difficult
redeeming jamie fox electro that's the
highlight of the trailer it is really
cool he does look very very very very
cool sent us to six
yeah
um interested to see what everybody
thinks i i feel like you know they
certainly know how to make a trailer
that's always been a thing that's
definitely not changed uh i'm i'm
excited it looks dope
very exciting stuff